AN EXECUTIVENDINF PR IGNED
RIGHTS.
E ET SERVICES TH ISSUE A REPORT
OUTREACH, PROVIDE NEW LEGA
ASSISTCECTD
KIT IS A RTEGLA.I
HOT  THE CAMPAN TR
>>epE BATTLEGROUND
STATE OF NEVADA, THE BATTLE OF
>>OMAN'SO ISSUE.
>> Reporter: -- MALIWOMEN LIKEA.
THI  18.PUBL
>> HOW AOUD? 1-10,
>> THAT'S PRET.>> Repr:H TO
SENATE
NOMISUPPORCRAT.
ER ABORTION CESS INTO THE STAT
CONSTITUTION.
THEN A YOTWO ONE OF THSTR TOTO
CONVINS.
IN THEDTERM ON THEEE
OF ROEDE BEINGFISHER FEAT UNSPU.
>>INK THIS IS GOING TO
RACES AND ESPECIALLY IN THIS HO
WE KNOW.NK A MORE
I RE DO.
>> O AGAINST ME -- WOULD BE THE
ABORTION BAN.EVANS ABORTION RIGN
ISSUE  HR AWAYPUBLIC
LAX ALT.
RIG IS FIGHT R WHAT
>> ANDHERE'S NO ON
TRUSTWORTHY  ADAM.
>> Reporter: HE HAS SAID H
HONOR THE CONSTITU
AUDIO
REVERSTHCONSTITUTION.
JOKE. A TOTAL, COMPLETE
INIOWE ARE NOT A PRO-LIFE STATE.
WE'VE GOT WORK TO DO ON THAT
RIGHT TO ARE OUTRAGED BECAUSE I
.ND STD
>> ReporFRONT AND CENTER AMONG R
CTING THEI
POCKOK>> GAS PRIS, GCE PRICEL T.
WT  POWBOUT
HOW YO
S DOWN RO
GROCERSTORE, OTHERRATS
SAY ABORTION RIGHTE VITABUT SO
AND I'M  OF DEBATING ON WHY.
I'M NOT GOING TOIE.
>> CATHERINE CORTEN
THE BALLOT.
>> YES.
>> WILL YOU BER HER?
IACTUALLY.
MAYBE.
HAD.M PLAYG IT BY RIGHT FO
>> SENATOR CORTEZ MASTATE TALKIN
NOT JUSTO WOMEN BUTO WORKING